[Music]
I was Britney's [ __ ] last night onstage
at Radio City Music Hall Andy Cohen had
the time of his life at Britney Spears's
piece of meat concert in New York City
the Bravo star was handpicked from the
crowd to participate in the now infamous
freak show number
[Applause]
yep that's the watch what happens live
host acting as Brittany's personal
plaything down on all fours crawling
across the stage but Andy isn't the only
celeb to rock the harness for Britt
Britt I actually appeared in Britney
Spears Vegas show Kathy Griffin took the
stage in 2014
cheering this pic on Twitter after the
show writing spent last evening with
miss at Britney Spears here in hashtag
Vegas woke up with rug burns what
happened you know I've known as since
she was 16 but the comedian later
revealed that the pop star didn't
recognize her during the onstage reunion
I said you know Britton so great to see
you and then she didn't know who I was
Colton Haynes had his moment with the
singer too the arrow star captioned the
clip quote still in shock made my Vegas
debut he later tweeted I hope I get a
residency now lol
look closely and you'll see Backstreet
Boy how IDI wearing a leash and shaking
it like a pro then there's Tyson
Beckford who's starred in Brits toxic
music video
[Music]
Britt tweeted a special thanks to the
actor after he jumped onstage with her
writing quote your dance moves over fire
and not to be outdone nicole richie all
of a sudden her dancers come over to me
and they just whisper get on all fours
and i'm like okay who totally fangirls
when she got pulled onstage
britney walks me like a dog spanked me
with a whip all right all right this is
it was the greatest moment of my life
[Music]